PETER BARRON: Good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen.
it's a reassuringly
full house.
For the latest of our Learning
From Leaders sessions, we're
delighted to welcome
Gavin Esler.
BBC presenter, correspondent
of many years, former
colleague of mine at Newsnight
for several years.
And we're absolutely delighted
to have you with us.
Gavin is here to talk about
his latest book.
He's written several books
over the years.
It's a terrifyingly
large workload of
novels and factual output.
But he's written a handful of
novels, which are highly
recommended.
They're actually really good.
His latest is "Lessons From
the Top," which is stories
about leadership and how you
great leaders become great and
stay great by telling stories.
And actually, it's an extremely
engaging read,
'cause it's mainly gossip and
anecdotes about the many
people that he's interviewed
over the years.
So Gavin's going to talk for
20 to 30 minutes, and then
we'll be happy to take questions
from the floor and
the various offices.
Gavin?
GAVIN ESLER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks very much.
It's really good to be here.
It's so nice to see
so many people.
And despite what you've read
in some of the newspapers,
this is not a greater number
of people than the average
Newsnight audience.
We're doing very well,
thank you very much.
And thanks to Peter for that
kind introduction.
I am always incredibly nervous
about introductions, ever
since-- and you'll see this
partly reflects in the book--
introducing Alastair Campbell
at an event a
couple of years ago.
And he said to me, how are you
going to introduce me?
And I said, I'm going to
introduce you as Tony Blair's
former press spokesman.
He said, oh, that's all right.
He then went on stage and he
said, it's a big improvement
from the introduction I got last
week in Leeds, when I was
introduced as, please welcome
Alastair Campbell, the most
evil man in Britain.
So I'm very careful about the
frame in which things go.
And at least because I've known
Peter for many years, he
knows who I am.
I was on a plane recently,
coming back from the Far East.
And one of the stewards came up
to me and said, Oh, I'm a
great admirer of your work.
Would you like some champagne?
Thank you very much.
Have a drink of champagne.
And during the course of the
next 20 minutes, he told me
what a great bloke I was, how
fantastic my reporting was,
how he'd watched everything that
I'd done, and was really
just one of my best
fans and admirers.
He slightly spoiled it at the
end, when he said, I've got to
attend to other passengers.
But what's your next assignment,
Mr. Alagiah?
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, I'm here to talk about
that leaders and leadership,
which is something which really
engages me, actually.
What makes an effective
leader?
And there are all kinds of
qualities that leaders have.
They have to be persistent.
They have to be creative.
They have to, quite often,
be idealistic.
They can also be
quite annoying.
But if you don't have any
followers, by definition,
you're not a leader.
And you don't get followers
if you don't
communicate with people.
And I became very interested in
how leaders do communicate
with different audiences.
It's obviously different
culturally, different in
different countries, it's
different in business from
perhaps in the military.
But there are similarities.
And what really sparked off this
book was the 2010 general
election campaign here.
I was doing quite a few
interviews for Newsnight.
And one night when I was off, I
switched on another channel,
and there was Alastair Darling,
the chancellor of
exchequer, during the worst
economic crisis of my
lifetime, facing Piers Morgan.
And Piers Morgan said to him,
so tell me, chancellor, are
you good in bed?
And I realized, at that point,
this was where my career had
gone completely wrong.
Because I'd never thought
of that question.
And I thought it was
very strange.
Anyway, Alistair Darling
batted it away.
But during that election
campaign-- you may remember--
or that period, Nick Clegg was
asked how many lovers he had.
David Cameron was asked, have
you ever committed adultery?
And how did you get your
wife pregnant?
Pretty much the way most people
get pregnant, I think
was the answer.
Again, he kind of
batted it away.
But I thought, would Mrs.
Thatcher have been asked any
of these questions?
Or Churchill, or de Gaulle,
or even John F. Kennedy?
Looking backwards, would anybody
have been asked these
questions 30 years ago?
What had changed in
our media culture?
What had changed in our
political culture, and in our
popular culture, that made these
questions seem, to some
people, the sort of questions
that you would ask on
television of the people trying
to run this country?
And I became--
I started to go backwards and
think about all the leaders
I'd met over the past 25, 30
years, and think, what do they
have in common?
What stories did they tell, and
how useful could that be
to the rest of us, both in terms
of the stories we tell,
and also seeing through some of
the constructions that they
put on their own
personal story?
So just to back up a minute--
we are all--
you are all--
storytellers.
You told a story to
get a job here.
It might have been in your CV.
It might have been in
your interview.
But you did tell a story.
You tell a story when you go
out on a date, frankly.
You tell a story when
you ask for a loan.
You go into a bank and
say, I've got this
great business idea.
Oh yeah?
Who are you?
Basically, that's what the bank
manager wants to know.
It seems to me that there are
three basic stories that all
leaders tell.
Who am I?
Who are we as a group?
And what is our common
purpose?
Or where is my leadership
going to take you?
I'm less interested in the third
part of that, where's
our my leadership going
to take you?
Because if the leader doesn't
solidify the first two-- who
am I, and who are we?-- you're
not going to listen to where
they want to take you anyway.
So let me give you
a few examples.
Mrs. Thatcher, seems to me, had
one of the best "who am
I?" stories of anybody, when
she said, I'm just the
grocer's daughter
from Grantham.
So those six words, which she
used repeatedly and her people
used repeatedly to try
to sum her up.
Grocer's daughter, not son, so
different from the past.
From Grantham, not part of
the metropolitan elite.
And a grocer's daughter.
Now each part of that
was true, but did it
entirely sum her up?
I mean, did anybody think she
was serving behind the counter
a little, for example?
I don't think so.
So she told a story in a
particular way which really
stuck and really helped her.
Bill Clinton, the first
time I met him, did
something very similar.
He said to me--
this was before he was running
for the presidency.
He said, well, you know, I'm
just a boy from Hope.
Meaning the town of Hope,
Arkansas, where he grew up.
It was a few years later, after
I spent some time in
Arkansas, that I realized that
he kind of grew up there, but
he also grew up in Hot
Springs, which
is a gambling town.
Curiously, that was not the
story he chose to tell.
I'm the boy from the
gambling town.
I wonder why.
I wonder why he chose Hope.
And so even from the start,
you can see that
we all shape stories.
You've shaped your CV.
You shaped whatever it was that
you told people in the
interview for the job
that you've got now.
Clinton shaped his story.
It wasn't untrue, but it was
not the whole truth, of
course, about him.
"Who are we" follows
on from that.
Just to take care the example
of Ed Miliband and David
Cameron and the recent party
conferences, three or four
months ago.
Ed Miliband told this
"who am I" story.
I'm the son of Jewish
immigrants.
I love this country because they
gave my parents a home
when all Europe was likely
to suffer the
tyranny of the Nazis.
That's quite a compelling
"who am I" story.
The "who are we" story--
well, I'm not old Labour.
I'm not new Labour.
I'm one nation Labour.
The same--
in a different way, I suppose,
because it's a different
story-- but the same technique
is used by David Cameron.
He's defined himself in various
ways personally.
Talked recently about his father
and the struggles that
his father had.
He talked, of course, about the
struggles he's had as a
father, and the loss of a child,
which is a terrible
part of his story.
But it is something that we all
have in our minds when we
think about him.
He also told a story about
being a compassionate
conservative.
And that's one of the
interesting phrases that I
really love, in terms of
a "who are we" story.
Because I first heard it in 2000
in Philadelphia at the
Republican Convention.
And the person telling the
"I'm a compassionate
conservative" story was
George W. Bush.
I'd never heard the
phrase before.
I was standing with a long-time
friend who's a
Republican.
I said, what is this
compassionate conservatism?
And he looked at me and said,
it means anything we were in
the past that you don't like,
we're not that anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
But anything in the past that
you do like, we're still that.
That's also an interesting
technique that I haven't got
time to go into, but it's also
been used by Deng Xiaoping in
China, quite a similar
technique, when he said, after
Mao, and after being purged
a couple of times by the
Communist Party, when it was
likely that he was going to
assume the ultimate leadership
position, he defined himself
as practicing socialism with
Chinese characteristics.
Anything we were in the
past you didn't
like, we're not that.
So some things do translate
from one society and one
culture to another, in terms of
the kind of techniques and
the kind of storytelling
techniques that leaders use.
"Who are we" and storytelling
might not actually be words.
I suspect that a hero of many
of you, as it is for me, is
Nelson Mandela, partly because
he gave up power.
But his story is
extraordinary.
His autobiography is
And there were a couple of
moments in it which show a
different way of telling
a story.
When he was first arraigned
before an apartheid court, he
turned up wearing traditional
Xhosa dress.
He didn't have to
say anything.
I mean, you just look at him,
and the story is, here is an
African man in a white man's
court, and he's not going to
get justice.
That was his story.
He didn't have to
open his mouth.
And many years later, if any
of you are rugby fans, as I
am, you'll remember that in the
1990s, when South Africa
hosted the Rugby World Cup,
there was President Mandela
telling a very different story,
sitting in the stand
wearing a Springbok shirt.
And again, if you're familiar
with the politics of South
Africa, the Springboks had been
associated with white supremacy.
And he was saying, we're
different now.
This is a different nation.
Get used to it.
We're the rainbow nation.
So even in matters of dress--
and that's too many other
leaders, too.
It was true of Jinnah, in
Pakistan, in a slightly
different way.
Just the way you look can be a
way of telling a story about
who you are and who
we are as people.
I've become interested in all
sorts of parts of this,
including counter-stories and
how leaders deal with
counter-stories.
I mean Mrs. Thatcher, the
ultimate counter-story about
her was "Mrs. Thatcher, Milk
Snatcher." But the actual
counter-story, which worked to
her advantage, was when the
Soviet newspaper called her The
Iron Lady," thinking this
was a criticism.
Can you imagine what it must
have been like in Downing
Street when they heard the
Russians had called Mrs.
Thatcher the Iron Lady?
Thank you, Lord.
Thank you.
And of course, she used
that to her advantage.
Obama is an interesting
character in these terms,
because he got his retaliation
in first.
He wrote an autobiography many
years before he was running
for the presidency, in which he
revealed, for example, he'd
used drugs.
So that issue, that part of
his "who am I" story, has
never come up.
Nobody cares about it, because
he neutralized it before
anybody could dig it out
and reveal it to
the American people.
But he has also run into
severe problems on
his "who am I" story.
It's very interesting to me,
in the last election, that
while people can legitimately
criticize his health care
policies or what he's done on
the economy, a lot of the
criticism of Obama wasn't
"where's my leadership going
to take us," that third
part of the story.
It was on the first part.
Who are you?
You're not really an American.
You're a Muslim.
You're not a Christian.
You weren't born in
the United States.
I mean, those stories could have
been, particularly if you
were not born in the United
States, very, very
damaging for Obama.
And difficult to handle,
actually.
He handled it, I thought, rather
brilliantly when--
I don't know if you remember,
but he released his birth
certificate showing he'd
been born in Hawaii.
So there was the facts
of the case.
But he also appeared
at the White House
Correspondents' dinner.
And Donald Trump, who was
possibly going to be a
Republican candidate and was one
of those in the so-called
birther movement--
who had questioned Obama's
right to the presidency
because he may not have
been born in America--
Trump was there.
And Obama said, I have
released my birth
certificate this week.
But tonight, I'm going to do
something that no American
president has ever
done before.
I'm going to release
my birth video.
Now this was a formal dinner,
and people had just eaten.
You can imagine the reaction.
The lights went down.
Up behind him on the screen
like this, there was the
opening sequence of Simba
being born in
"The Lion King." [LAUGHTER]
Now that's a kind of political
genius in storytelling, it
seems to me.
Because he's saying, I don't
take this seriously.
Of course he took
it seriously.
But he's taking it seriously
by appearing
not to take it seriously.
And we never heard of Donald
Trump again, at
least in that election.
Very, very clever
moment for him.
One of the things I also focus
on is what I call star
moments, something they
always remember.
I've noticed that a lot of
leaders do something in a
discussion like this or when
they appear on television,
when they're making a big
speech, something
that really gets you.
And they do it when they
meet you, as well.
I mean, I said Clinton said,
I'm just a boy from Hope.
It's one of the things
he obviously
thought I should remember.
The first case for me was in
Northern Ireland, when I was
scheduled to meet a paramilitary
leader that I
knew had blood on his hands.
And I sat in a rather dingy
office in Belfast by myself,
waiting for this fellow.
And he walked in, and he
came straight up to me.
He didn't say hello.
He just said, I am speaking to
you as someone deeply involved
in violence.
I didn't need to take
notes, actually.
I got the point that
he was making.
But it works in business,
as well.
Bill Gates is a good example.
When he was trying to raise
money for the campaign against
malaria and AIDS in Africa--
particularly
malaria, in this case--
he appeared before an audience
of potential donors with a
large jar filled with
mosquitoes.
And as he's talking, he starts
to unscrew the lid on the jar
of mosquitoes.
And the punchline, as he gets
the top off is, so I don't see
why it should just be the poor
who have the opportunity to
get malaria.
Guess what?
He got quite a lot of money from
the potential donors, and
they never forgot it, I
would suggest to you.
One other technique that a lot
of leaders use in different
ways is what I call a violation
of expectations.
You expect something
from somebody,
and you get the opposite.
Perhaps because they confront
the worst thing that you were
thinking about.
It happened with Alastair
Campbell at that conference
that I was at, when the said
he'd been called the most evil
man in Britain.
It's a very, very clever way
of making people laugh, and
also seeing that you understand
some of the things
that are going on in people's
minds about you.
It also happened with a woman
I think is quite an
extraordinary leader, Michelle
Bachelet, who was the
president of Chile.
The first woman president of
Chile, the first woman defense
minister of Chile.
And when I met her a few years
ago, I asked her how difficult
it was for her to run a country
which has got a very
macho reputation, with a very
macho military, where her own
father had been murdered by
the military after the
Pinochet coup against
Allende in 1973.
Her father was a socialist.
He was a doctor, I think,
and a social democrat.
He was murdered.
And she said, well, I thought
particularly being defense
minister would be very
difficult, because I would
have to be the boss of the
people who, if they were not
directly responsible for my
father's death, were part of
that political culture.
So I said, how did
you handle it?
She said, well, I called in all
the admirals and generals
an senior air force officers,
sat them down, and said,
hello, I'm your new
defense minister.
I'm a woman, a socialist, an
agnostic, and I'm divorced.
All the sins together.
But we'll work very well.
I think that also is a kind
of political genius.
Because she is saying to them
what was already in their
minds and confronting it, and
violating every expectation
that you wouldn't actually talk
about the nasty things
people think about you.
I think that is a kind of real
leadership genius, because
you're facing the facts about
yourself, and you're
communicating that you get it.
In her case, in quite
a witty way.
And humor, of course,
is pretty important.
I want to leave as much time
for questions as I can, but
just a couple more points.
One is the words that you use,
or the words that leaders use,
are quite important.
I'll have to refer to a couple
of notes here, because I can
never remember this list.
But years ago, when I was
based in Washington, the
Republicans and the
Democrats--
rather like now, actually, over
the budget-- they had a
terrible standoff in the 1990s,
and it led to the
shut-down of the US federal
government.
Clinton was the president.
Newt Gingrich was the Speaker
of the House of
Representatives.
And they made pretty much,
actually, the same arguments
as John Boehner and Barack
Obama are making today.
But Gingrich is quite an
extraordinary figure, in terms
of communication.
Because a few years before
that, he circulated to
Republican candidates and
Republican activists a list of
words to use about yourself,
and a list of words to use
about your opponents.
Here's the words to use about
yourself and your policies--
candid, care, challenge,
children, courage, debate,
dream, family, hard work,
legacy, liberty.
For your opponent,
he suggested--
bureaucracy, cheat, collapse,
corrupt, cynicism, decay,
destroy, destructive,
failure, and so on.
You can make up your own list.
But this was a kind of
all-purpose toolkit.
And it was used by
some candidates.
And as you may well have
noticed, it is still being
used today by politicians
in this country and, in
translation, by lots of
other politicians.
The thing that doesn't work,
and one of the reasons, I
think, why we're all somewhat
skeptical of
leaders in public life--
politicians in particular--
is that all-purpose toolkit
has no values.
It doesn't actually tell you
what they're going to do.
It just says, you're
Mr. Nasty.
You're responsible for
corruption and decay.
I'm Mr. Nice.
I'm responsible for
dream and children
and family and liberty.
And the bits in between
don't seem to matter.
And I think we get--
I think the British people
certainly get-- the Newsnight
audience, believe me, really
do get-- that there's
something quite cynical
about this.
And they dislike being
manipulated by a vocabulary,
which is there to blow a whistle
and make you perform
certain tricks as a voter.
Vote for me and not vote
for the other person.
Just a final thought.
I've talked quite a bit
about leaders that I
think most of us get.
Most of understand why Mandela's
a great leader, or
why Mrs. Thatcher was a great
leader, even though she was
divisive here at home.
Some leaders that we don't get
in this country also interest
me greatly.
George W. Bush and Ronald
Reagan are two American
leaders that are have been
routinely caricatured in the
British press, in a way that I
think is unfair to British
leaders and British voters.
Because roughly 50% or
more of the American
people voted for them.
We have to understand that.
What is their attraction?
And so simply caricaturing them
as cowboys, or in George
W. Bush's case, someone who's
misunderestimated, who can't
speak English, it's a bit of
fun, but it's rather silly.
It doesn't get to the point of
America, why the most powerful
country in the world produces
leaders that we just don't
understand.
And part of the reason they
connect with their own voters
is their great storytelling
skills.
And when I say that sometimes
to British
audiences, they go, what?
George Bush, great storytelling
skills?
Absolutely.
If you look at the way he
presented himself down on the
farm in Crawford, Texas--
dusty old jeans, open-neck
shirt, pickup truck,
raking up the brush.
He says in his autobiography
about his background, he says
pretty much the same kind of
story that most American
political leaders tell.
We were honest people, family
was important to us.
We didn't have to lock the doors
at night, because we
were a decent neighborhood.
He was the son of the President
of the United States.
It was a good story.
A great story, actually.
And a very attractive story
to people who thought,
he's just like us.
OK, so he doesn't do the
fantastic grammar.
Fine.
I understand him.
He's the sort of guy I'd like
to have at my barbecue.
That is a story which really
connects to people.
Ronald Reagan is the other
one who, I think, was
misunderestimated here, for
the power with which his
stories connected to people.
And I'll tell you a couple of
Reagan stories, then leave it
and take some questions.
Michael Deaver, who was--
I think he was deputy
or assistant White
House Chief of Staff--
told me he was actually
responsible for
making Reagan look good.
And so for example, if Reagan
was going to make an
announcement about
the environment--
let's put it this way.
He wouldn't fit into
the Green Party--
Deaver would stick him in a
canyon in the western United
States with an open-neck
shirt and a horse.
And whatever he said, it
would look fantastic.
This is somebody who cares
about our environment.
It's wonderful.
Because pictures are really
important, too.
Deaver told me a story about the
kind of charm that worked
with his own staff.
He told me that there was one
night when there was a
terrible political crisis,
foreign policy crisis, and
questions about whether troops
should be deployed, were
Americans under attack?
What should happen?
Now Reagan himself had a
fairly relaxed of work.
So you didn't work through
the night personally.
But his key staff did
work through the
night in the Oval Office.
He breezed in the following
morning at 9 o'clock, very
cheery, good-humored as
usual, with his dog.
Which ran round and round and
round his desk, really
irritating these guys who'd been
up all night, plotting
how to defend the United
States of America.
And one of them finally said,
one day, Mr. President, that
dog's going to piss
on your desk.
And Reagan said, well,
everyone else does.
[LAUGHTER]
And another story which
connected to a friend of mine,
who is a journalist, when he was
a very young journalist in
the Middle East, he came back
through Washington and was
going to his head office in New
York when he was called
into the White House to talk
about the situation as he saw
it, in the region
that he was in.
My friend--
not much older--
has got a magnificent beard.
And he had a magnificent
beard then.
Reagan asked him a few questions
and then said, so,
what's next for you?
And he said, well, I'm going
to New York to meet my
editor-in-chief.
But before I do, I'm going to
have to shave my beard off.
And Reagan said, why are you
going to shave your beard off?
He said, well, the
editor-in-chief thinks beards
are scruffy and nonprofessional,
so
I'm going to do it.
So that's what he did.
Went to New York, and then
went back to Beirut.
A couple of weeks later, his
editor-in-chief called him up.
What the hell did you say
to President Reagan?
He said, well, how
do you mean?
He said, well, because I had
a breakfast with him with a
number of newspaper editors
this morning, and I was
berating him for his
ultraconservative, illiberal policies.
And he said to me, I might
be ultraconservative and
illiberal, but I'd let
a guy wear a beard.
[LAUGHTER]
Now my friend was not a great
Reagan supporter, but he
really liked the guy.
He absolutely liked
and respected him.
It connected with him.
That was a story.
It was nothing to do with the
policies, which he, in his
journalism, found to
be the subject of
real, invalid criticism.
It was to do with the person.
So that's important.
Storytelling's important.
You can learn how to do it.
You can learn how other
people do it.
And you can begin to see
some of the constructs.
Because these stories are not
fully formed, like rocks of
gold in the river.
They are something that people
make in order to entertain or
attract you and make you think
they'd make a good leader.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BARRON: [INAUDIBLE].
Now we've got half an
hour for questions.
Prepare your questions.
Microphone's [INAUDIBLE].
I'm deeply interested
in when [INAUDIBLE]
about that.
Perhaps also about Dan Quayle?
GAVIN ESLER: Oh, Dan Quayle.
Yes, well Dan Quayle was known
as being not the sharpest tool
in the toolkit when he
was Vice President
of the United States.
One of the things that you must
do, it seems to me, is
recognize your own failures and
not dig yourself in deeper
into a hole.
So if you're a Dan Quayle, and
you're with a 10-year-old or
12-year-old, and there's a board
behind you, and you get
him to spell potato--
P-O-T-A-T-O is what the
12-year-old put--
don't put an E at the end of it,
as Dan Quayle did, because
you dig yourself even
deeper in a hole.
And it meant that stories about
him abounded, even ones
that probably weren't true.
He went on a tour of
Latin America.
And he was quoted in some places
as saying, aw, gee,
these are such great countries
down here.
I wish I hadn't given up
studying Latin in school.
I don't think he ever said that,
but it sounded as if he
could've said it.
So there are real potential
for catastrophes.
One which doesn't appear in the
book is one about the BBC
recently, which has not told
its story very well.
And I think people have
got to own up to that.
I think the people at the top of
the BBC now absolutely get
it, that there were mistakes,
there were quite serious
mistakes, and you have
got to confront them.
And you've got to show people
that you confront them.
And this wasn't done
with the greatest
competence, it seems to me.
And that's one of the reasons
why people lose jobs.
Another good example, which
is in the book,
is BP and Tony Hayward.
I talked to a lot of people
about the Gulf oil spill, a
lot of people in the oil
industry, and they were all of
the view, actually, that the
catastrophic killing of 11
people, the Gulf oil spill, the
environmental catastrophe
and so on, was terrible.
But after it happened, in
technical terms, BP did what
any other oil company
would have done.
They tried to get it right,
and they tried to fix it.
But their storytelling--
particularly Tony Hayward's
storytelling--
was appalling, and is used by--
again, I quote in the
book, a CEO of another big
company that I didn't even
want to name--
they use it as a test case for
how not to handle a disaster.
Because every company--
the BBC is one--
will have big problems.
You always have big problems.
But the way to get round those
problems, or convince people
that you can get round them,
is to be honest, to confess
the truth, to face up to
it, and to say you've
got a handle on it.
And also, it seems to me--
it's a lesson I didn't have
time to go into, Peter--
but one of the things that's
interesting is if you say, I
got this wrong, I suspect that
people will respect you.
Because they think if you got it
wrong and it's your fault,
you may have the capacity
to put it right.
Whereas if you say,
it was his fault--
which politicians have
a tendency to do.
It's all the Europeans, or the
Chinese, or it's the other
people, people who were
in office before me--
which they will do.
I suspect that many of us lose
respect for them, because
they're not taking control and
taking charge, in a way that
most well-run businesses
do take charge.
AUDIENCE: Before anybody else.
PETER BARRON: You may not
get away with that.
OK.
Questions or thoughts?
AUDIENCE: While they're doing
that, Gavin, if I can be rude
and ask a question--
as you enter your seventh decade
next month, can you
tell us about your daily
beauty routine?
GAVIN ESLER: Well, I was asked
what beauty products I
recommended, and I couldn't
think of any.
And then I thought,
actually, water.
I shower.
[LAUGHTER]
GAVIN ESLER: I brush
my teeth in it.
And I drink it.
Can't recommend it to highly.
AUDIENCE: What advice would you
give to Lance Armstrong,
who he's been telling a story
to [INAUDIBLE] next week?
GAVIN ESLER: Yeah, well, I mean,
not to start from here,
is one obvious place.
Tell the truth.
Just tell the truth, you know?
And if you tell the truth, you
have the opportunity to shape
the truth in the way
that you want.
Because as I suggested to you
right at the start of this
conversation, in a CV,
you don't tell
everything about yourself.
You may be asked what your
weaknesses are, but you're not
going to parade them.
So it seems to me, if Lance
Armstrong wants people to take
him seriously, he's got to tell
us what he did, why he
did it, and explain it.
And I think, actually, my
sense is that people--
not in this case,
I don't know.
But people are pretty
forgiving.
We forgive people for making
mistakes if they own up to it.
The question of Barack Obama
using marijuana and cocaine is
a non-issue because
he admitted it.
He said it was stupid.
Not only that, in his
autobiography, he says, I
could have gone down
that route.
That is a road that I could
have taken, but I didn't.
I stopped.
And I think most of us
get that, because
we understand it.
It was true of Clinton, as well,
when he talked about the
trouble in his marriage
at various points.
And when he did that right at
the start, or just before he
became president, that
helped him through
the Lewinsky affair.
So when you do something really
stupid, you have to
tell the truth.
The fact that Clinton lied at
the start of that didn't get
him off in the end.
What got him off in the end
was the American people
listened to the truth, and they
were pretty forgiving,
even though they thought he
did something stupid.
So in the case of Lance
Armstrong, I would suggest a
similar kind of thing.
I actually have a chapter in
the book which I call the
Angelina Jolie Method, which
is about how she confronted
the fact that people thought
she was a bit
of a Hollywood airhead.
Learned about Cambodia, learned
about landmines,
learned about what happens.
Became a UN Special Ambassador
or Special Envoy, whatever it
is, and does good work by
traveling around the world to
places like the Syrian border.
She's been in West Africa, she's
been in Darfur, and so
on, places that you wouldn't
go as a tourist.
Now she'll still get the
nonsense in the popular press.
But I think people do give her
credit for doing some good.
So you can tell stories and
reinvent yourself if you
confront what people are
actually saying about you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GAVIN ESLER: I think I'm going
to have to write another book
about that.
But to do it briefly, do would
you remember, right at the
start of this conversation,
I talked about the kind of
questions that were being asked
about Alastair Darling
and others?
Now I know none of them went
into politics to be asked
questions about, are
you good in bed?
None of them when into
politics for
that kind of scrutiny.
I argue in the book, but it's a
quite complicated argument--
I argue that in the past 30
years, our media culture has
changed significantly because
of developments in--
there's a lot more of it.
There's Google and
other things.
So everything is available all
the time, almost everywhere.
24-hour television.
Confessional TV--
Oprah Winfrey and the same
kind of shows here.
I actually have great respect
for Oprah Winfrey, but there's
others I don't have much respect
for, including some of
the programs here, where people
are expected to parade
stories about their
private lives.
The "Hello!
Magazine" factor.
"Hello!
Magazine" was actually invented
in Fascist Spain at
the end of World War II, as
"Hola!" But the idea behind
it, which is you get to know a
little bit of the real life of
a celebrity in exchange for
they give a bit of their
privacy, has invaded all
our media, everywhere.
And "Hola!" or "Hello!"
is everywhere, too.
It's in more than 90
countries now.
Now you take all these
things together--
if you're in politics, you
look at, is it easier to
appear on TV and talk about your
family, your children,
your past life, who you are,
what a nice fellow you are?
The fact that--
Michelle Obama keeps talking
about how Barack Obama doesn't
pick up his own socks
in the White House.
Is it easier to do that than to
tell us how you're going to
fix the economy?
I think it is.
And I think anybody who looks
at the kind of scrutiny--
I don't mean, are you fiddling
your expenses?
That's all completely
legitimate.
But if you look at the other
kind of scrutiny, or at least
stories that some aspects of
our media expect leaders to
tell, it's really off-putting
for talented people who are in
business, or who've got a life
doing something else.
So it's a slightly
long answer.
It seems to me that these are
very difficult times, and we
will dislike anybody leading
us at the moment anyway.
That's part of it.
But the question is whether
you respect them.
Because I think in America,
even those who disliked
Reagan's leadership respected
him as a person.
In this country, Margaret
Thatcher's leadership was very
divisive, but people tended to
respect her and take her at
her own value.
When she said, I'm the Iron
Lady, or the Soviets called
her that, and she adopted
it, nobody really
questioned who she was.
You disliked her policies,
perhaps, or you liked them.
But you didn't question
who she was.
Now it seems that people don't
do anything else before they
go into politics, very often.
They become obsessed with the
process of politics, which
most of us are not
obsessed with.
And the kinds of stories they
tell or we expect them to tell
are very odd, and
very different.
David Cameron cycling to
work, for example.
That's interesting, but he
obviously doesn't do that as
prime minister.
And he was caught out with
his change of clothes
behind him in a car.
Those kind of stories, we
understand that we're being
manipulated, even if we
don't really think
about it every day.
Just to give you one final
example on that.
Tony Blair, in his
autobiography, talks about his
preparation for an election.
And he was hugely successful,
obviously.
Three landslides.
Most successful Labour
leader in history.
You might have thought that
preparing for an election, he
would figure out economic
policy, and what to do about
Iran, or whatever.
But he's got a very eloquent
passage where he says, you
know, I was sat down by my
advisors and asked, how much
is a kilo of lamb?
How much is a tin
of baked beans?
What's a pint of beer?
If you buy bread, which bread
would you buy, and how much
would it cost?
A pint of milk?
And those kind of questions.
Nothing whatsoever to do with
why he was hired by the
British people to do a job.
But he knew, or at least his
advisors knew, that if he
thought a tin of beans cost 20
pounds, or threepence, we
would think he was out
of touch with us.
So it's partly our fault--
I mean, as voters.
It's partly that the
media has changed.
And it's partly that the people
who decide to go into
politics have to be slightly
different from the rest of us.
Otherwise they wouldn't
put up with this.
Hope that answers
your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Gavin.
Quick question around negative
campaigning.
I watched the US election
coverage, and when Romney gave
the Obama camp that gift, they
were on TV the next day with
that, saying, he's not
the man for America.
And I just wonder, why do you
think that's so pervasive in
the American elections, and
not so much over here?
And do you think that
really works?
This people trying to tell a
negative story about you?
Because I think in this room,
there's a lot of people out
there trying to say negative
stuff about Google a lot of
the time these days, and we have
to try and combat that.
GAVIN ESLER: I think--
it's funny, actually.
When you ask people, does
negative campaigning work?
They say, oh, no, we hate it.
But it does work.
That's why they do it.
And there's much more of it in
America, because under the
First Amendment, they have the
right to freedom of speech.
So you can say more.
And they float on a sea
of money, as you know.
Their elections are incredibly
expensive.
It doesn't work for everybody,
but it probably works for some
people, who haven't quite
made up their minds.
And I think--
I think you're being
slightly too
generous to Britain, actually.
I think we also have it here.
I mean, some of it's
absolutely fair.
It's absolutely fair for
conservative politicians to
attack Labour on their economic
record, or Labour to
say these welfare reforms are
going to hurt people, or
whatever it is.
That's just the daily business
of politics.
But there are some quite nasty
things that appear in
campaigns, and have appeared
in British campaigns.
Perhaps slightly more subtly
than America, because we're a
different audience.
But it does happen here.
One of the lessons that I draw--
and I use one of the
American parallels, which is
John Kerry being portrayed as
if he was some kind of coward
in the Vietnam War, when he
was a decorated soldier.
And he was facing a candidate in
George W. Bush, who didn't
fight in Vietnam, who was in
Texas Air National Guard.
Now both of those are perfectly
honorable positions.
But it does seem to me to be
pretty incompetent of the
Kerry team to allow themselves
to be painted as if you war
record and your Purple Hearts
aren't worth anything.
That was a huge mistake.
And so one of the things I say
very strongly is if you don't
defend your reputation,
nobody else is going
to do it for you.
AUDIENCE: Gavin, just
following on
from Ollie's question.
And you mentioned almost a
change of perception over
generations or time.
Leadership being almost an
extension of personality--
and a lot of the stories, you
said, were people effectively
projecting their personality or
challenging misperceptions
of their own, and the strength
of leadership being
a function of that.
But we see political parties
or the political system
becoming more technocrat, and
more to your point, the story
with Tony, about being
effectively fed what was to be
his world view, in terms of
cost of a loaf of bread.
And then in companies, we also
see heavily orchestrated story
lines about brand
and position--
well, I guess you could say
Apple being another extreme
example where the two align.
Is there a danger, or do you see
already, that leadership
decreases as those leaders are
unable to project themselves
away from what the position of
the party or company is?
GAVIN ESLER: Well,
I think that is a
really interesting question.
I go into a little
bit in the book.
But I mean, take Steve Jobs as
a good example that we're all
familiar with.
I mean, if Steve Jobs were
here with us today and
presenting a new Apple
product, you
know how he'd be dressed.
Just like you know what the band
KISS are going to look
like when they come on stage.
You know what he
will look like.
Even with Lady Gaga, you don't
know exactly what she's going
to look like, but you've
got an idea.
And with Steve Jobs, he comes
in, open-neck shirt, none too
clean jeans, pair of trainers,
here it is.
This is fantastic.
I'm a cool kind of geek,
is the story.
I'm not corporate--
while running one
of the biggest
corporations in the world.
So that was obviously a great
strength for Apple.
But it also a weakness, with
his passing, perhaps.
Who knows?
It may take a long time.
Richard Branson is another
good example.
Everybody knows what Richard
Branson looks like.
Everybody knows what
he looks like.
Do you know what the people
running the other train
companies in this country
look like?
Don't think so.
Probably middle-aged white guys
in suits, we would guess.
So there's real advantages in
that, it seems to me, because
the product is himself,
and also his
company, and they're attached.
And it's a very good way
of getting free media.
But there are dangers
in it as well.
Because if that leader either
dies or is discredited in some
way, or makes some terrible
mistake, as we've seen in
banking, where some of the bank
leaders became kind of
superstars--
Fred the Shred, for example--
then it's a very, very
long way to fall.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GAVIN ESLER: That
surprised me?
Oh, lots and lots of surprises,
actually.
Dolly Parton surprised me.
All kinds of ways, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
GAVIN ESLER: She's one of the
brightest women I've ever met.
She'd make a fantastic
political leader.
I like her music as well.
She surprised me because--
I don't know if you remember,
but a few years ago, the
reason I was interviewing her
was that she released an album
which is basically covers
of 1960s protest songs.
And it was during--
I think it was the end of the
Iraq War, which was very
messy, and while the Afghanistan
conflict
was still going on.
And I was suggesting to her
that releasing an album of
1960s anti-war protest
songs was quite a
strong political statement.
And I have to say that she
danced around that question
more brilliantly than any
politician I have ever met.
Including when I said
to her, well, you
should go into politics.
She said, honey, there have been
enough boobs in the White
House without mine.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'd--
I'd love to hear your views
on the recent BBC crisis.
What did the director
general get wrong?
And what should he have
done differently?
GAVIN ESLER: Well, there's
quite a lot there.
[LAUGHTER]
GAVIN ESLER: We've only got,
thank God, 10 minutes.
Look, there were clearly big
mistakes that the [INAUDIBLE]
inquiry has gone through,
in terms of what was
commissioned, what was not
commissioned, and so on.
One of the things, though, to go
to my theme, is how do you
tell a story?
I mean, I'm very proud
to work for the BBC.
Really proud to work
for the BBC.
I'm very proud of the
people I work with.
And like viewers, I feel
let down if they
don't get it right.
Now sometimes, we all
get things wrong.
We all get some things wrong.
And sometimes, there
are reasons for it.
If you explain it, and you still
have got it wrong, but
it you explain it properly,
as I suggested, people may
forgive you.
So in terms of the
commissioning or
non-commissioning of a
program on Savile--
the one thing that the BBC's
never pointed out, it seems to
me, is kind of obvious,
really--
there wasn't actually
a program to run
in December of 2011.
There was some research
and some interviews.
There wasn't a program,
you press a
button, you've got one.
When all that research was
handed to ITV, who did a very,
very good job with it--
excellent job.
Really congratulate them.
But it took them till October
2012, which is what, ten
months later?
Because these things
take time.
So it wasn't as if,
here's a program.
We didn't run it for
various reasons.
I had nothing to do with
it, by the way.
But it just seems to me, in
terms of basic communication,
you should point out to people
that there was some research,
which the editor at the time
didn't seem to have any faith
in, didn't think was going
anywhere, which is a
reasonable point of view.
He may have been wrong, but
it's a reasonable point of
view to take.
And it took ten months,
because these
things take a long time.
So communicating that,
I think most people--
you may not forgive
the mistake.
I don't know.
It's up to you.
You're viewers as well.
But if you begin to understand
it, I think you might
understand the processes
that go on.
And for example, as Peter well
knows, when you commission
anything that's investigative,
it takes a long time and is
very hungry of resources.
I did a film on the INLA, which
took me and the producer
three months.
So it was three months of our
salary, where I didn't do
anything else.
It was three months.
This was years ago,
in Ireland.
So it takes time.
The mistakes that were made,
it seems to me, should have
been confronted earlier, and
the BBC should've made its
case, which is a reasonable
case to make.
It's by far, certainly
not a perfect case.
But it's a reasonable
case to make.
They didn't make it properly.
I hope that they're
making it now.
And I think there's a
degree of calm and
common sense returned.
And also, for all of us, as we
found out this shocking story,
we found out that it wasn't just
the BBC that was duped.
It was people in the
NHS, in was people
in the Prison Service.
It was--
Mrs. Thatcher had Christmas
lunch with this guy.
You know?
So there's quite a lot of
explaining that could have
been done that wasn't.
That's the corridor.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] examples
of why "who am I" stories are
important for a leader, do you
suppose the reason that we
look down on American leaders so
much is that the "who am I"
story is more important to the
people directly following
you-- the voters--
than people looking from a
distance, who care much more
about, where are you taking the
country, or the world, in
the case of America?
GAVIN ESLER: I think that's
absolutely right.
And I think also--
I have a bit of fun in one of
the chapters, where I quote, I
think it's six American
presidents, or wannabe
presidents, quotes from
their biographies or
autobiographies, what they
say about themselves.
And I don't mention who they are
until towards the end of
the chapter.
And you would think they're all
the same person, because
they all tell broadly
the same story.
We were poor, but
we were honest.
We lived in a log cabin.
Da, da-da, da-da, da-da.
Because they think, or somebody
around them thinks,
that's the story that connects
best with them.
And it is true that people who
come from a humble background
and get on, we tend to admire,
because we like that story.
And that's true everywhere.
People who come from a really
prosperous background, like
George W. Bush, have got a
different storytelling trick
that they've got to pull.
Osama bin Laden's another
one, actually.
Again, a completely
different culture.
And the storytelling that
he did, for most
of us, is just ludicrous.
Absolutely ludicrous, .
But for the audience that he was
looking for, the idea that
he's fighting the crusaders,
appearance on horses, the
white robes, the Kalashnikov
in the background, the holy
books, tells a particular story
for his audience, which
doesn't work with people outside
that target audience.
AUDIENCE: How well do you
think Google is going at
telling its story?
GAVIN ESLER: I'll have
to google it.
[LAUGHTER]
GAVIN ESLER: Well, I mean,
you've got some great bits of
your story, it seems to me,
which is that you've got
worldwide recognition.
As you--
that great cliche.
When you become a verb
as opposed to a
noun, that's not bad.
There are clearly problems.
And it's the same problem
that Microsoft had.
When you become big, somebody's
going to hate you.
And it's not just your rivals.
People just don't like
the big bully that's
going to bully us all.
And so that seems to me to be
one of the obvious weaknesses.
And what do you do about it?
Because you are big.
You're big because you're
successful.
And how do you steer
around that?
How did Microsoft?
I mean, I think one way to do
it is to look at how others
have done it.
How did Microsoft do it?
How did Steve Jobs
do it with Apple?
That was, to me, a really
clever model.
But it worked for him because
it was authentically him.
He was a showman, actually.
He liked to do that.
A lot of companies don't have
people who want to put
themselves forward.
And actually, that's not
part of the ethos.
But I don't know enough
about the ethos here.
But I suspect that's not quite
the way that you want to go.
So you've got to find out what
is authentic about your story,
and tell that, and tell
the good bits.
And know that there will always
be people who will
criticize you.
I mean, the tax question
is a really big
issue in this country.
And I hope we will continue to
get people from Google on
Newsnight to talk about it.
Because it's something which
concerns everybody.
But you've got to recognize
that, and I think you do.
AUDIENCE: Current crop of shadow
cabinet and cabinet
politicians, who are the
best storytellers?
And then, who are the best
storytellers on their behalf,
in terms of their teams?
Do you think they're
doing a good job?
GAVIN ESLER: Ah, that's
a good question.
I don't know.
I mean, to put it another way,
I could go through the whole
cabinet, but it probably
wouldn't be a great idea.
The ones you tend to hear
of tend to be the better
storytellers, tend to be.
There's some stories that are
not particularly well told, it
seems to me.
I mean, I think the question
of the railways is a really
interesting story.
I mean, you could tell--
I'm not going to give advice to
people in government about
how to tell that story.
But there seems to me a much
better way of telling a story
than it's been told so far.
And the same is true of
the shadow cabinet.
I mean, it seems to me in terms
of in Ed Miliband's
case, he's being criticized
for the third part.
What are your policies?
I actually think that's
something that really
exercises political journalists,
and doesn't,
until we get closer to the
election, really exercise
ordinary folk.
I think what does energize
ordinary folk is,
who are you, exactly?
You know, the confusion, David,
Ed, all that stuff.
I'm sure he understands it.
He's a very bright guy.
But that story still
needs a bit more
telling, it seems to me.
Who are you, and why should
we be interested in you?
Because I think we are like
that, as a nation.
And I think that the polls,
they reflect as much, it's
hard times for everybody.
So some people are very hostile
to the government.
Rather than a positive,
we're looking at the
other parties here.
And we won't do that until we
trust the person that we think
is going to be in
Downing Street.
AUDIENCE: So you've obviously
had a lot
of people on Newsnight.
But who always says no, and who
would you love to interview?
GAVIN ESLER: That's very easy.
I have got two people that I
would like to interview most,
in ascending order number.
Number two, Bob Dylan.
And number one's the Queen.
I mean, seriously.
Tonight on Newsnight, Her
Majesty, the Queen.
You'd watch, wouldn't you?
And you'd probably watch
the Bob Dylan one, too.
That's very easy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Hopefully a straightforward one
to finish, Gavin, but all
the great leaders you've
interviewed, how many of them
are telling their
own true story?
Or how many of them are telling
a story that's being
spun for them by an Alastair
Campbell of this world?
GAVIN ESLER: Well, I'd say a
couple of thoughts to that.
One is, you said many
great leaders.
I've met a great many leaders.
I never said I met many
great leaders.
I've met very few
[LAUGHTER]
GAVIN ESLER: Just to
be pernickety.
I mean, one of the things--
I use the spin word occasionally
in this, but
actually, I don't think
it's very helpful.
I think when you call something
spin, you just mean
the story that you're
being told that you
don't entirely believe.
I mean, were the Apostles
spin doctors for Jesus?
Or I often think, who are
the great storytellers?
Moses--
he didn't just say, I've had a
walk in the desert, here's 10
rules, and you're all going
to live by them.
He said, I've been up on a
mountaintop, and God himself
has given me this stuff.
It's a great story.
AUDIENCE: You interviewed
him, then, did you?
GAVIN ESLER: Moses would
be number three.
[LAUGHTER]
GAVIN ESLER: The Queen,
Bob Dylan, Moses.
And so I think that
everybody--
including you, I would suggest,
with respect-- shape
your own story when you
talk to people.
We all do it, and there's
nothing wrong with that.
Nor is there anything wrong with
getting help to do it.
What's wrong is lying.
And some of them lie, or come
very, very close to it.
And all I've tried to do in the
book is give suggestions
to help everybody about
storytelling, but also to give
some suggestions for how to
see through when the story
you're being told is really
just a bit [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So if I can only just
add that-- so, who's then
been the most authentic?
GAVIN ESLER: Oh, I don't
know, actually.
The most authentic.
I'm not sure--
I'm not sure I could answer
that, actually.
I'll have to ponder.
AUDIENCE: Reagan.
GAVIN ESLER: Reagan.
Yeah, what you see
was what you got
with Reagan, I suspect.
Yeah, that would be
one good example.
Anybody who wasn't found out.
I mean, the thing about Reagan,
the thing about him,
in terms of storytelling--
and again, hugely, hugely
divisive figure.
Peter's right.
Thanks for the prompt.
You know, when he got into
terrible, terrible trouble
about the baronial factions in
his administration, who would
reef against each other and
they would do different
things, and he was supposed to
be the CEO, as it were, of
America, but he wasn't really
paying attention to
everything.
He was once asked about this,
and he said, well, I guess the
right hand doesn't know what the
far right hand is doing.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's kind of
vintage him.
It diffuses it, but there's
the premise.
And what's your next question?
It's very difficult
to think of it.
So maybe he's a good example.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PETER BARRON: Thank
you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
GAVIN ESLER: Thank you.
Thank you.